disparos en kabul y en jalal-abad donde
varias personas murieron tras la
dispersión del talibán de una protesta
mi corazón está aquí por esta bandera
mate y nos disparen contra nosotros
nunca dejaremos esta bandera son las
primeras víctimas después de la
intención del talibán de ofrecer una
imagen amable al mundo en aras de
conseguir reconocimiento pero los
expertos no se fían
están esperando su momento hasta que nos
vayamos de kabul luego comenzará el
derramamiento de sangre cuando no haya
periodistas y extranjeros para verlo lo
sabemos por eso es tan importante que
saquemos a estas personas vulnerables
ahora y pongan
evacuaciones que prosiguen a pesar del
caos ya se han sacado unos cinco mil
afganos diplomáticos y personal de
seguridad esto es washington donde
familiares esperaban la llegada de sus
seres queridos desde afganistán
paralelamente a las evacuaciones los
desplazados estos jóvenes llegaron a
turquía el lunes si no piensa en volver
y hay guerra en mi país que puedo hacer
allí si no hubiera habido guerra nunca
hubiera venido aquí en la esfera
institucional también sigue el baile de
dirigentes el ex presidente es rafa ni
llegó a abu dhabi donde fue acogido bajo
el argumento de razones humanitarias
por el contrario barádar akhund con
fundador del talibán regresó a
afganistán después de 10 años en el
momento en el que el talibán trata de
consolidar su gobierno con la
cuestionada promesa de no volver a
esconderse al mundo